thanks for stopping by welcome to
PlayStation granade now today we are
looking at Easter eggs in Tom Clancy's
Ghost Recon wildlands we have a host of
movie references secret locations and
generally weird and bizarre happenings
here in Bolivia so let's get to this and
start with one that gave me the chills
on the far right of the map is a swamp
you can travel to it's located just
south of the nearest fast travel point
when you approach the location is
identified as childhood a few hundred
feet away take out your drone and fly
over the makeshift campsite to see a
young boy who looks pretty happy the
gunner object well if you get to hello I
guess he will turn and run into the
bushes and a few seconds later he
vanishes into thin air replaced with an
explosion of leaves there's a document
nearby too and it tells of a young boy
who went to assist his mother who was
washing clothes but when he entered the
water he mysteriously disappeared did we
just meet that boy the campsite is
filled with teddy bears and kid toys
which really back up this story and make
it feel a bit unnerving I wanted to see
if he really was a ghost so I shot him
from quite far away it turns out you can
murder ghosts sorry little boy why did
you just kill the civilian another
mysterious location can be found in the
lower left corner of the map in nuevo
mundo which roughly translate as the new
world this area cannot be mapped on your
map but once you discover it you can
fast travel there in this village all
the inhabitants are descended from
airplane crashes from around the Andes
Mountains it also shares many
similarities with the film and true
story by the way alive in which the
community find ways to survive in
sub-freezing temperatures using the
cleanse room in there is even a cemetery
similar to that which the survivors of
the film created for their fallen
comrades
this is overlooked by a huge cross to
mark the crash site if you didn't know
about flight 571 I recommend the book I
recommend the documentary and I
recommend
the film to appreciate what happened and
what the survivors end yad sadly the
film have ethan hawke in it so i'm sorry
about that
another film reference can be found in
the salt flats in north Kewanee a single
leather chair sits upon the endless
backdrop of pure white salt it could be
a random inclusion in the game but
people are suggesting this is a homage
to the matrix and the constructs seen
when they always learning about cutting
into the matrix and defining what is
real
I'll let Morpheus do the honors weapons
training simulations anything we need
right now we're inside a computer
program is it really so hard to believe
are the wild land developers reminding
us that we're playing a game and we
should probably go outside into the real
world now let's keep playing if you take
a trip over to Barba course I have no
idea from saying that right I apologize
anyway if you go to this location there
is a palace which looks mighty similar
to the towers found in early Assassin's
Creed games if we get closer the
similarities continue on top of the
tower are four extensions which were
used by the assassins to jump from and
look one of them even has an eagle
perched upon it I'm sure you remember
the Eagles flying around the vantage
points on Assassin's Creed right if that
wasn't enough there is even a container
at the foot of the jump just like those
haystacks we frolicked in as out.i air
all the memories
I wasn't sure whether to include this so
here's a quick shout out to dog town in
attack WA yep it's a town only inhabited
by dogs as all the people have
mysteriously vanished are probably being
taken by the Santa Blanca it supporters
were forbidden to see the town's nib but
what the heck yo bull hey I'm still okay
let's crack on you can't make a video
game without a Dark Souls reference
these days it's the law so if you want
to see wildlands version get your
backside over here and take a short walk
over the hills assault on fire as made
popular by Dark Souls if you haven't
played Dark Souls then don't ever try it
because it will ruin your life by the
way the flaming sword is a bonfire exact
soul and is used as a checkpoint but
it's so pleasing to the eye that I just
stood here because I wanted to see it in
daylight and night light - yep I'm that
sad there are few unlockable costumes
which arguably are Easter eggs - the
first is from another Tom Clancy game
the division and them expecting other
Ubisoft costumes to be added over time
but the second one is called dying earth
which I believe is a nod to Mad Max if
you don't know who Max's I demand you go
back and watch Mad Max Beyond
Thunderdome
it's easily the best in the series and
came at a time where thumbs could be
ridiculous and still be loved bed and
it's also before milky and went a bit in
you know weird Road Oh
[Music]
there's a few unexplained secrets in
wildlands I'm including even though I'm
stuck at the next step
all around Bolivia you can find these
strange rock piles which I use for
prayer one in particular is more
important and can be found in Inca
kameena what makes it so special well
it's this small Idol placed on the
ground nearby by interacting with this
little stumpy booger it suddenly jumped
onto one of the altars any
self-respecting Easter Egg hunter could
not turn down this challenge so off I
went to find the other seven I'm
completely lying about that because I
just waited for the reddit community to
find them all and then I went to get
them staying in and around Inca kameena
and traveling over to one of the highest
points in the game by the way there is a
Ubisoft achievement providing this spot
here at the top of the mountain is yet
another totem which I'm going to call
Gary interact with him and just to check
that this works I went back to the
ritual spot to see if Gary made it home
okay PPA is fine let's grab the others
just south of the Kewanee salt flats is
yet another totem on a very high point
and just look at the view you get for
picking this up over at this point in
Libertad there is also another High
Point with another totem and yet another
lovely view
next get your backside over to Malka in
this spot there is a small estuary with
one of the totems taken in the view of
the lake in the top right-hand corner of
the map is a waterfall search around for
a fallen tree this will lead you to yet
another bloody statue for the next one
in San Mateo you will need a chopper
this little booger is just such looking
over the valley so pick him up if you
get the chance we got to find it first
come on over in Aqua Verde is the
hardest little blighter to find because
it's slightly under water in a small
village called Playa Sarina go to this
exact spot or risk looking around like
an idiot for 20 minutes yes I am that
idiot with all the idols collected we
can travel back to Inca kameena and look
at our handiwork we did it and the
locals are having the time of their
lives
lighting candle and having a silent rave
sadly that's it
no single Adi happens after this or at
least I can't figure out what to do next
do you have any ideas please let me know
below
dr. Georgia Menace billion that ain't a
mission [ __ ] there are four hidden
buttons in Ghost Recon wildlands that
explicitly say do not press but of
course no one can tell us what to do
press those goddamn buttons the first
can be found in a burned down forest in
la Cruz where this happens
[Music]
the second button can be found to the
southwest of the original starting zone
by the dam for this one I recommend
waiting for nightfall
the third button is on the salt flats of
Kalani
here's [ __ ] genius
I think Wow look you're a [ __ ] genius
I think you suck you uh I'm the best for
last the Angel of Death a top of the
mountain in Malka I have absolutely no
idea what these fireworks displays are
here for but I'm glad I press those
buttons [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] genius I think you sir
well pure [ __ ] if there are any buttons
that I've missed please let me know in
the comments below
finally the myth of the Yeti is
currently sending the community wild but
it's yet to be spotted in the game for
over ten hours I've spent wandering
around the mountains but I can't find
anything except a few dead bodies with
scratch marks on them as evidence what
also feeds into this by the way is a
downloadable Yeti hunter costume and
there are also some files around Bolivia
which hint at this white Beast
I suspect the Yeti will be added in a
future update or maybe a DLC because if
I'm honest I just can't look anymore I'm
sick of the sight of snow do you have
any clues to offer have you spotted it
yet yet please let me know I'm dying to
find the big bastard anyway we've
reached the end a whole source of Easter
eggs collectibles and secrets that's has
been on earth but the Yeti remains a
mystery for more videos like this one
please like and subscribe I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade I'll see you next
time